(gentle techno music)
- You could pick up and take your factory
that was making something
right here in Brockton,
and put it over one mile
across the border in Mexico.
- Our annual deficits
went over a trillion dollars.
they’ve been reduced significantly.
- This year's pretty
interesting, and it's not like
any other year that there
has been an election.
- They've turned this election
into what they have done
and not enough about what they will do,
and that's important,
obviously, to everybody.
Even if it is a choice I
would make or if it's not
a choice I would make, I
have to be open-minded.
Just to understand the
people that are living
in the same country as
me, considering the fact
that I only live in Boston,
I only travel in Boston,
it was really cool to see
other people's point of views
about who they believed
would be more beneficial
as president.
- And kids are actually
in a small enough group
and where they feel it's
safe to have an exchange,
they really share some
pretty deep thoughts.
Something about being here,
I think, gets kids to think
bigger in some way, because
you just, at some level,
I think the kids sense that
these are serious things
and they really make a difference.
- Business.
I wanted to know what
candidate Clinton's plans are
for American manufacturing.
- I think the interesting
space around manufacturing,
and I think it reflects here
in Massachusetts as well,
is that there is a new level
of manufacturing, a precision--
- For me it was pretty
intense when you have somebody
who disagrees with you.
It's really important to
understand their point of view,
it expands your mindset.
- Instead of just reading
it or just watching them,
I actually got to see people
that run in their campaign,
and see what the people
in their campaign believe,
and how they'd support their candidate.
- [Man] To give you, that
distinguish these candidates.
Breitbart News.
- You have to all understand each other
in all different types of backgrounds.
Just not be ignorant
about some type of people
or creating scapegoats.
You have to find out the best solutions
for day to day problems.
- I do believe that we are the future.
We're the upcoming faces,
and that's really important
that we understand what's
going on in our country.
(gentle techno music)